savait faire le mort c'est pas anodin
doit être solide psychologiquement c'est
vrai que faire le mort c'est pas donné à
tout le monde c'est pas évident mais ce
qui est si vous voulez participer au
concours ces faits là il faut un minimum
d'équipement l'oms suggère du scot
scotch ricol de préférence et ça marche
toujours mieux ça fait gagner du temps
et également une crée alors une fois que
c'est fait y a plus qu'à se glisser dans
sa trace moi je fais toujours des
grandes traces comme ça ça permet de
pouvoir pour avoir un certain nos pics
de mouvement et puis évidemment attiré
mans fermer les yeux et enfin leur
ressembler le plus possible ce qu'on
appelle l'amour
non je rigole un holistique voilà non
joué face avant qui a pas d'endroit
crédit fini pour faire le mot c'est
vraiment ce que l'ap les accidents de la
vie j'ai envie de vous dit bonne chance
a mal géré a dit non à visionner des
milliers peut-être les centaines de
milliers de participants en course très
dure sélectionnera les habitera la
première pour une ou deux personnes
peut-être 3 vous voilà maintenant vous
fait le mort